[Música]
es un placer saludarlos Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y le hizo la bienvenida a
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
con una imagen fortalecida y una
renovación al mandato del presidente
chillín terminó el vigésimo congreso del
partido comunista chino que congregó a
más de 2.300 delegados analizaremos la
importancia conclusiones y repercusiones
de este evento para la región y el mundo
Indonesia ordenó prohibir la venta de
jarabes para la tos mientras Investiga
la muerte de casi 100 menores de edad
por fallos renales Aparentemente por
haber ingerido esta sustancias con
componentes perjudiciales para la salud
en nepal las autoridades han prohibido
que en lugares sagrados históricos y
religiosos se graban videos de tiktok
por considerarlos molestos
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en China en donde
durante una semana se llevó a cabo el
vigésimo congreso del partido comunista
que otorgó al presidente chillín un
nuevo mandato el tercero de manera
consecutiva el masivo encuentro se
desarrolló en un momento de coyuntura
tanto nacional como internacional esto
debido a una ralentización en la
economía local como consecuencia de los
constantes cierres por la política de
cero covid impulsada por el gobierno y
las diversas tensiones políticas y
diplomáticas con occidente para conocer
los detalles y conclusiones de este
cónclave que se realiza cada cinco años
en China nuestro corresponsal en Beijing
Adrián foncillas nos envió el siguiente
reporte
el vegésimo congreso ha terminado con
sisentino más fortalecido al frente del
partido se esperaba que consiguiera un
tercer emérito mandato como secretario
general que renovará en la jefatura de
la comisión militar se esperaba también
que las enmiendas constitucionales
fueran aprobadas para apuntalar su
pensamiento en el centro del partido y
se esperaba también que la renovación
del comité permanente y el poliduro
reflejarán su auge imparable lo que no
se esperaba es que pudiera llenarlos al
completo de sus fieles y que no dejara
ni un solo resquicio a otras voces en
este congreso han quedado sepultadas ya
las corrientes que han dominado la
política china durante las últimas
décadas el plan de Shanghai y los la
liga de las juventudes del partido
castigadas por la alta edad de sus
dirigentes y por la campaña
anticorrupción de Sí el ex presidente
yang semin de 96 años ni siquiera acudió
al congreso y el ex presidente ajuy
taudes 79 hubo de ser evacuado a la
fuerza por problema de salud en una
escena cargada de simbolismo en este
congreso se ha profundizado en la
tendencia que empezara 10 años atrás un
poder cada vez más centralizado eso
agiliza la toma de decisiones en un
contexto cada vez más hostil pero reduce
la posibilidad del debate interno cabe
reseñar también que por primera vez en
décadas no habrá ni una sola mujer entre
los 24 miembros del polípuro Pero cuál
es la importancia de este congreso
previamente hablamos con Raquel y Samara
psg en Asia y estudios de China también
profesora e investigadora de negocios
internacionales de la Universidad
Autónoma de Puebla y directora del
observatorio de la política china y esto
nos respondió la cuestión de Por qué es
tan importante este congreso es de
alguna forma por cómo se rompen ciertos
esquemas dentro de la política china si
bien a nivel interno pareciera ser que
es una simple dinámica de un partido
Pues bueno China es un estado que tiene
características
muy peculiares en las cuales el partido
determina el estado y obviamente el
estado en esta dinámica en Cómo se
posiciona china a nivel internacional en
donde pues prácticamente estamos viendo
ya la ejecución de una reforma
constitucional donde después de
convierte en el presidente con un tercer
mandato dentro de la historia reciente
de China y en ese mismo tema Pues bueno
es como esta visión de estado que se va
a tener Durante los próximos años
principalmente hacia el 2035 con la idea
de la sociedad modestamente acomodada y
también hacia el centenario de la
creación de la República popular china
donde Pues están temáticas como Taiwán
como el caso de Hong Kong y Macao en
esta reintegración de de la gran nación
China
también le preguntamos a Raquel y Samara
que representa la figura de Pink tanto
en el interior del partido comunista
como en el país
prácticamente con este congreso que está
haciendo es generar una clase de
estrategia en la cual pues es
simplemente cerrar algún tipo de
fragmentación dentro del propio partido
este comunista no principalmente por qué
Porque en la estructura de partido
siendo en este caso secretario general y
e inmediatamente la figura de presidente
de la república popular China desde los
últimos 10 años se ha podido ubicar a
dos facciones dentro del partido este
comunista una en donde pues ha sido
liderada de manera natural
por este chilling Pink que es conocido
como los príncipes y por otro lado que
son los famosos Pampa y que que ha sido
de alguna manera representada por la
figura de El hasta hoy ya con un cambio
interesante de Primer Ministro como lo
es este liques ya no donde prácticamente
Pues llega con un nuevo grupo de este de
hombres cercanos hacia lo que es esta
parte del polígono en la cual pues
prácticamente se construye un nuevo
gabinete dentro del partido comunista
chino donde prácticamente también vemos
cómo se pone fin a una era anterior
principalmente liderada por la idea de
las reformas de este de en shopping y
Que obviamente el cierre simbólico de
todo esto es la imagen que vimos todas y
todos de La retirada de este huying Tao
dentro de el cierre de la de la
Ascensión que viene para china en los
próximos cinco años bajo el continuado
liderazgo de Pin esto nos dijo nuestra
invitada
en este tema creo que la parte económica
va a seguir siendo ahí como el reto a
vencer obvio en este punto los ajustes
ajustes que hace el partido desde la
visión de el sismo o el liderazgo de
esta cuestión de la autosuficiencia
tecnológica no donde prácticamente china
quiere ya pasar de ser un país este que
dependa digamos del exterior para
motivar su mercado Y en este caso pues
bueno tener como este tipo de
autosuficiencia en distintos niveles de
la producción y sobre todo en cuestiones
de innovación que es hacia donde se ha
planteado esta visión de planking quenal
eh que está este corriendo dentro de
China no y en esta misma dinámica Pues
bueno es un tanto también el contexto
tanto geoeconómico como geopolítico en
el cual este pues bueno está digamos
tensión con Estados Unidos se hace
visible a través de este tipo de
estrategias ojo aquí un punto
interesante también con este
eso es una lectura sobre el tema de La
regulación de la de las empresas o la
propiedad privada donde se deja ver una
Nueva Visión en la cual se impulsa en
cierto tipo de de empresas pero también
el hecho del control sobre ciertos
capitales para que de alguna manera se
alinean todavía muchísimo más la clase
empresarial hacia lo que es esta visión
de estado partidista liderada por Shin
pin agradecemos a Raquel y Samara por su
análisis cambiamos de tema y vamos a
Indonesia allí el gobierno ordenó de
tener la venta de todo tipo de jarabes
tras conocerse las muertes de casi un
centenar de menores por fallos renales y
las cuales estarían relacionadas con
estos medicamentos y sus componentes
alerta fue emitida por la Organización
Mundial de la Salud que también informó
el deceso de varios niños en gambia en
el oeste de África por la misma razón
uno se simples jarabes para la tos han
despertado preocupación en Indonesia
recientes datos del Ministerio de salud
indican que al menos 99 niños han muerto
en lo que va del año debido a un fallo
renal asociado a estos medicamentos
hasta el 18 de octubre las autoridades
sanitarias identificaron 206 casos de
esta enfermedad
como medida preventiva el Ministerio ha
pedido a todos los trabajadores de la
salud de todos los establecimientos de
salud que dejen de recetar o
proporcionar temporalmente cualquier
medicamento líquido o en jarabe hasta
que finalicen nuestras investigaciones
la delicada situación fue dada a conocer
por la Organización Mundial de la Salud
que emitió una alerta sobre cuatro
jarabes contra la tos y el resfriado
producidos por el laboratorio indio
Maiden farmacéuticals que Podrían haber
provocado la muerte por fallo renal de
más de 60 niños en gambia en el oeste de
África
los análisis de laboratorio según indicó
la OMS revelan que cada uno de los
jarabes contiene cantidades excesivas de
dietilenglicol y etilenglicol sustancias
altamente tóxicas para la salud las
cuales pueden causar vómitos diarrea
dificultad para orinar y lesión renal
aguda que puede llevar a la muerte sin
embargo por el momento las autoridades
indonesias han afirmado que estos
productos no se encontraban disponibles
en el país Las investigaciones se
centran en conocer Las verdaderas causas
de la muerte de los menores Y si el
medicamento responsable es un producto
importado o producido localmente
la aplicación tiktok es un éxito mundial
pero no todo el mundo es fan algunos
lugares históricos y religiosos en nepal
han prohibido que se graben videos para
intentar frenar el flujo constante de
jóvenes que cantan y bailan dentro o
frente a estos atractivos turísticos
durante meses estos lugares sagrados de
nepal han sido testigos de una
peregrinación inusual
de jóvenes que cantan y bailan por los
lugares pintorescos del país mientras
graban contenidos para tiktok
esta tendencia ha hecho que lugares
emblemáticos como este templo de
katmandú se han invadidos por
adolescentes armados con sus teléfonos
viene a ver el templo pero sobre todo
para tiktok pero de molestos los
usuarios de tiktok tendrán que buscar
otros escenarios para sus vídeos las
autoridades nepalesas han prohibido el
uso de la aplicación en determinados
lugares de interés como este monumento
budista en la capital
Esta es la prohibición de tiktok pueden
hacer fotos a veces aquí pero no el
tiktok los influenciadores llegaron
hasta este lugar para grabarse con
música a todo volumen día y noche
durante meses
usan palos de selfie y luego bailan y a
veces toda la multitud de gente también
hace el tiktok molestan a la gente que
camina que rinde culto aquí
pero también se ha prohibido en otros
lugares históricos del país ya que no
solo los lugares sagrados atraen a los
influencers nepalíes
los campos del centro de nepal también
se han convertido en un escenario
favorito este agricultor está harto
porque dice dañan sus cultivos
miren pasan por aquí y lo destruyen todo
pisotean todos mis brotes de arroz Pero
qué puedo hacer
esto les digo que se detengan que no
destruyan mis Campos Pero ellos siguen
bailando dicen que no están haciendo
nada malo
en los últimos dos años el número de
usuarios de tik token nepal ha aumentado
en casi un 2000 por ciento
y para el cierre les dejo algunos datos
se estima que hay más de 2.000 lenguas
diferentes en Asia estas son algunas de
las más destacadas chino o mandarín
hindi urdu árabe indonesio japonés
coreano tailandés inglés y español esos
dos últimos en algunos países son
considerados idiomas Asociados
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web france24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]